[موسيقى]
الحدود التالية تحت الماء لأن
لدينا إمكانية الوصول إلى مساحة كبيرة
غير متوفرة على الأرض. تتمثل
مهمة هذه التكنولوجيا في
تغيير الزراعة لمنحها
إمكانية إضافية لزراعة المنتجات على مساحة
هائلة من سواحل البحر الأبيض المتوسط.  الأرض
عبارة عن آلاف الكيلومترات من
المواقع المحتملة،
والمحيطات الحيوية تشبه العدسات اللاصقة الكبيرة
التي نثبتها في قاع البحر
داخل هذه القباب،
فنحن نلتقط الهواء بفعالية، إنه
حجم هواء محصور في مساحة مثبتة في
قاع البحر تحت الماء
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
مئات من الأنواع المختلفة  نباتات تتراوح
من الفراولة إلى الطماطم والفاصوليا
وبالطبع الأعشاب
[موسيقى]
لدينا اختلاف في
طيف الضوء الذي يصل إلى نباتاتنا لدينا
استقرار حراري بفضل
مياه المحيط من حولنا لدينا
انفصال تام عن مسببات الأمراض والآفات الخارجية التي
لا يمكن لأي شيء الوصول إليها  نباتاتنا
تحت الماء ولدينا إمكانية الوصول إلى
المياه العذبة التي يتم الحصول عليها بشكل طبيعي من
التبخر مما يعني أنها تتخلص من
محتوياتها الملحية وتصبح
مياهًا عذبة بشكل أساسي إنها تمطر داخل المحيطات
الحيوية
[موسيقى]
لدينا أنظمة مركزية لذا
نسبة الأكسجين ونسبة ثاني أكسيد الكربون ودرجة الحرارة
درجة حرارة الماء في الهواء الداخلي
والإضاءة بالطبع إذا لزم الأمر،
وآمل أن تصبح الزراعة تحت الماء
معيارًا بمعنى لا يجيب على
مسألة كيف سنطعم
العالم كله ولكن في المناطق التي
تحتاج إليها
أجنبية أجنبية.